let's let's play this video it's it's
our uh reaction right yeah we're going
to be talking about
i haven't seen it i think a lot of these
guys haven't seen it so
this will be the first time for everyone
here
it's it's weird when you live in a day
and age when candy bar commercials are
shocking and controversial but i mean
i've seen so much crazy stuff lately so
let's check it out
of course
at least they have the candy bar in
there
bite-sized halloween commercials they
don't even
that's so close on the logo at the end
[Music]
family friendly right
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
is the kid gonna answer the princess
[Music]
is
why are you all dressed up it's not
halloween yet
he's a boy
[Music]
can i help you are you a good witch or a
bad wish do you want to find out
i'm still wearing my princess dress do
you want to wear it
he's also wearing eyeshadow
or even the shirt underneath the girl's
shirt
hey you
princess
you look like a girl why are you wearing
that stressing like this makes me feel
good is that your nanny she looks weird
[Music]
that's an interesting message
what
so we're seeing a whole lot of this
stuff like with gonzo the the muppet
babies they did the same thing it was
gonzo everybody the other girls were
dressed like princesses the boys were
gonna be princes and they all separate
went separate ways to get in costume and
gonzo's just they're sad
and a little mouse comes out and says
well you said he's like well i want to
wear a dress but boys aren't starts to
wear dresses and he's like i'll make you
the best princess there is they won't
ask any questions you'll just wow them
or whatever and sure enough he got his
princess dress and when he came in
they're all like wow look at the most
beautiful princess
don't you love the mic drop sound effect
at the end of it yeah you share their
message yeah right i mean my thing went
to these commercial shows all the time
there's the adult presence missing the
parents are not there throughout the
entire thing
when they when the
boy dressed in a dress was interacting
with that other boy when he said oh
because it makes me feel good do you see
how he looked back at his nanny for like
validation from the adults and what did
she do she validated how we felt and
then and the adult is not the parent but
a nanny witch
yeah exactly exactly so it's just like
yeah why why why is there always the
removal of the parents the removal of
that moral congress
and i think it's always interesting
because the argument always comes um you
know
all this lgbt stuff it actually you know
causes um division and anger in people
and they're going to be like fighting
against them that's actually a comment
that came back on one of our channels
the other day was like why not to show
people anti-lgbtq
stuff because it creates violence but
doesn't that just create violence right
there i mean yeah that was that was the
answer to someone that doesn't agree
with me i'm getting all of a sudden yeah
and and if necessary use witchcraft to
do it
yeah i mean
that's a dangerous precedent
i just don't understand how
people can just think this is normal
this is a commercial about a candy bar
and
there wasn't a single picture it wasn't
yeah
nobody took it they weren't even eating
it
this is just a propaganda looking on the
twitter account um there's people that
are mentioning this exact same thing oh
wow so we're suggesting that you should
do violence and people that disagree
with you and stuff so it's not just us
reacting like that i mean look at that
this is actually
lgbtqnation.com and they're just showing
different responses on twitter
consider the like the magnitude like how
well this company must be doing to put
all that money into a commercial that
doesn't even have a product placement
anywhere it's just pushing this message
that they have and they slap the logo
interesting
i'm two minutes long all right two
minutes yeah that's a lot of times about
30 seconds
do you notice how actually some of these
commercials like we did with the satanic
shoes and stuff like that it seems like
if they agitate society that all of a
sudden people start sharing and making
posts exactly like what we're doing
right now and maybe that's like
literally what their motive is like yeah
you you cross ripples in the pond and
now people are going to talk about it
this is an interesting comment i don't
need to know the commercials to teach
kids to commit violence with magic
what is it teaching them yeah right that
twix are good i mean
so what is it you're supposed to look
below the surface that you know
you get validated and and get rid of
people or
man i used to like twix
[Music]
advertisers have targeted kids for
decades for the ones buying the products
or their parents presumably or the
parents giving them the money to the
kids to buy these things so
like who what's their audience the thing
is as a company who's out there to make
money
they're trying to be on everybody's side
and so when the tide is turning towards
any particular agenda then they're like
oh yeah we're on board with the agenda
because for them that's customers right
so i'll give you a prime example
uh just after trump got elected
and
um
he signed remember the muslim ban yeah
right
and there were 10 countries and
yeah you could not enter the united
states they were banned from entering
into this country right
so he did that
it was about two to three weeks later
that the super bowl aired
okay and on the super bowl that year
there were two commercials that were
very politically motivated one was by
airbnb and they just showed a bunch of
faces they weren't showing homs or
anything like that bunch of faces and it
was like we accept that was their
message it was like all these different
cultures and stuff and and i get it i i
agree we should be accepting of all
cultures and races and all that kind of
thing i understand what they're getting
at
the next commercial that i thought was
really fascinating was budweiser
and it was you were watching
uh adolphus
push i think it was go through the
process of immigration into this country
and then starting his you know brands he
partnered with somebody else you know
what what became budweiser the whole
point was he was an immigrant what's the
message we're on the side of immigrants
as a company
they're buying their product they want
to be on the side of immigrants right so
they're they're signed the president we
don't agree with you because at the end
of the day we're going to be on the side
of our customers and i think that's
exactly what's happening here so many
people are getting on board
with
that line of thinking and they don't
want to be left you know they don't want
to be canceled for not
being on board
so to meet their bottom line
they're gonna they're gonna get on the
train
and also the witchcraft you know i mean
they're using yeah just popularizing
witchcraft
yeah making it kind of and that's and
that's what witchcraft really is right
is it's i'm gonna use the elements or
i'm going to force
something to happen because i'm wishing
or i'm bending the will of the world to
my desire
yeah rather than how we should be
looking at it is really like what is
god's will and you know god is the one
that's in control not me
that's this is this is disturbing so i
think i remember the verse but i'll look
it up just to make sure but i'm pretty
sure it's ephesians chapter 4
verse 32 because this is one i'm always
going to my kids and be kind to one
another
tenderhearted forgiving one another even
as god and christ forgave you
right our approach and attitude toward
other people should be kindness should
be tolerance and we don't see a lot of
that in the world today
so
yeah that was a great ending
if you have any questions that you want
answered though check out the little led
show that we just did this last friday
questions q a's on halloween and uh you
know this is where this topic actually
came up so i don't know if you want to
ask another question or we can answer in
another video uh oh yeah my thing is you
think you really think people
would say like they have this decision
between a snickers bar and to explore
and they're like oh well i'm not going
to support tricks because they haven't
said anything about lgbtq i haven't put
their stamp of approval i'm gonna buy
the snicker people who like twix aren't
they just gonna buy twix is it really
that much of a moral thing that people
make that decision are they owned by the
same company
but chick-fil-a did that though didn't
they but they're still like a looming
fascinating restaurant so
why why all these companies feeling the
need to get so politically involved when
are is that really people's end-all when
it comes to the decisions
yeah i i would say that they're trying
to build um a like sort of
view of that company i would say that
they're they're probably in support of
that lifestyle or that whatever and so i
i'm saying that they're they're probably
putting that out there because that's
that's really what they're into because
it's more of their
i would say any company that's putting
supports for their values i think that's
kind of like where advertisers get a lot
of their um inspiration from it's like
apple puts forth their values and you
know i don't i don't know i think some
companies yes but i think other
companies know i think they're just
jumping on the bandwagon especially
during that month you know everybody's
logo is gonna be a rainbow know yeah i
think they're doing it yeah just but you
don't think they're the company's just
in support of that i feel like they
probably just separate it because it's
just like businesses business and money
is money so if you're in halloween
you're in the month of october you know
people are going to be buying candy for
trick-or-treating you're going to say
hmm
what can we do
to get our commercial out there and make
money and get more people to buy our
candy but like apple making commercials
where they're supporting the lgbtq you
know and having everybody wear that i
would probably say that that
company-wise
support of that but i wouldn't say every
company is yeah i would i wouldn't say
that there are certain companies i would
say yes totally totally they've been
promoting it and have been for a while
like apple's a perfect example they
didn't wait for everybody to jump on it
they've been on it for a while
but but yeah other companies i would
totally say they're just you know it's
like
you know
black history month you know comes
around and they're like okay yeah we got
to do
it's like
not it's and the point is it's not that
we shouldn't be aware of those things
and we shouldn't
we shouldn't um
be diverse and inclusive but it's like
they're just doing it just just to
please the customers i got another
question
what where does that leave us with so
many companies taking like a political
stance
how does that reflect when we make
purchases does
so so
you know apple has this dance or
whatever you're going to stop supporting
apple or you're going to stop buying
twigs does it really matter does it
really become a moral issue for each
person knowing company stands or can we
make these purchases and purchases in
world care i think if and when you can
make a conscious choice to choose
something else like um i remember when
there was all those oil spills and bp
was kind of like i used to ice filled
gas up there all the time because it was
cheap gas right but i actually purposely
avoided those gas stations because i was
like hey you guys should have been more
responsible with that and my little way
of supporting that is to not support
what they're doing and go buy gas from
somebody else
apple's a little different unless you
really want to just jump ship and go to
the pc world um you don't really have
the options there that you would even
know that you have the option anyway
because i think all the companies are
going that direction where they're
supportive like if you need a computer
for your job i think you're going to be
working on something
that they're on board with it
so then it's just a matter of what what
personal preference do i have for a
particular product i remember in the 90s
christians were boycotting shopping at
walmart because they were associated
with walden books and inside walden
books they sold playboy and it's like
wow and they're a bookstore that's
selling a variety of books and it's like
yeah you'd really not you could shop
anywhere really if you want to go with
association like that yeah you can't go
to a gas station because the gas station
sells
playboy books in there or cigarettes or
cigarettes yeah i mean
don't buy those products because of the
barcode that has a 666.
remember i don't know
i remember that yeah all right
cool
thanks for watching check out our video
led live every friday got a youtube
channel little light studios you'll see
it as our latest release on there thanks
for watching